ساعتين أو أكثر من ساعتين، قام بوتين
بتعليم كارلسون في نسخته من
التاريخ جيدًا، وكان من الصعب معرفة
ما إذا كان كارلسون بدا يشعر بالملل أو الارتباك
طوال المقابلة، كما
كرر بوتين بعض الأكاذيب القديمة مثل أن روسيا
لم تبدأ الحرب في أوكرانيا وكانت
تحاول ذلك.  لإيقاف ذلك، ظل بوتين يحاول
إثبات أن الأوكرانيين
والروس حسنًا، كلهم ​​روس، ها هو
الرئيس الروسي يستمع
إلى
هذا فجأة، كان الجنود الأوكرانيون
يصرخون من هناك باللغة الروسية
المثالية قائلين إن الروس لا
يستسلمون وجميعهم
ما زالوا يعرّفون أنفسهم على أنهم
روس، ما يحدث هو إلى حد
ما عنصر من عناصر
الحرب الأهلية، لذا ما هي الصورة الكبيرة التي تعرفها؟
الوجبات الجاهزة في كل هذا وهل
حصل بوتين على ما يريد من
المقابلة وماذا كان
ذلك جيدًا؟  أعتقد لنبدأ بما
أراده بوتين على الأقل أعتقد أن ما
أراده بوتين أولاً هو أنه أعطاه فرصة
للتحدث مع الجمهور الأمريكي
وهذا مهم حقًا لأنه يشعر
أن وسائل الإعلام التقليدية القياسية
لا تغطي ما يقوله وهنا كان
طريقة مباشرة لإجراء
مقابلة رفيعة المستوى كما تعلم للوصول إلى
الجمهور الأمريكي وأود أن أقول إنها
ربما تؤثر على انتخابات 2024 القادمة
أم هل نجح في ذلك،
فهذا غرض واحد لا أعتقد ذلك، لذا
أعني متى إذا نظرت  في
الطريقة التي بدأت بها المقابلة، استمرت لمدة نصف
ساعة مع أه، كما تعلم
تاريخًا مفصلاً لروسيا يعود إلى حوالي
ألف عام، كانت هناك نقطة واحدة بدا فيها
أم تاكر كارلسون
مرتبكًا بعض الشيء وأعتقد أن التاريخ كان
1654  ولم ننتهي من الأمر بعد، لذا إذا كان
بوتين يحاول التحدث إلى
الجمهور الأمريكي فسيكونون في حيرة من أمرهم، كما
تعلمون ما هو تاريخه، فهذا
مهم بالنسبة لبوتين.